طيب اذا قارنت جهود الولايات المتحده
لمواجهه منافساتها الصين في هذا المجال
كيف يبدو وضعها
الاجابه التقليديه هي ان الولايات المتحده
تقود في الرقاقات وتصنيع والصين متقدمه في
توافر البيانات البيانات وهذا المهم جدا
لخوارزميه تعلم الاله وكلا البلدان لديهم
صناعات قويه وبعد تركيز مختلف في كل دوله
انا شخصيا اعتقد بالنبات المتحده
وبريطانيا
يركزان اكثر من اللازم على حلول البيانات
الكبرى وفيها فوائد تجاري قصيره الامد الى
اداء الزملاء في المركز يخالفوني الراي
ولكننا نرى ان جوانب هامه من مجموعه
الاصطناعي في الصين
وتعلم الاله وهذا كان اصطناعي التقليدي
لمستقبل لاحد
ويضعون كثير من الموارد اقصده في الصين في
التكنولوجيا المستوحاه من الدماغ